something he knows well and where
there's minimal risk involved magnus
let's see what he opens with
okay one knight f3 very solid start one
of my favorite moves the reti opening
very flexible as well so uh not
too
adventurous here from magnus yet
what will we see him play next that's
the biggest rupture
[Laughter]
magnus is not going to do that he he
doesn't tend to experiment
during this critical rounds and uh here
he's playing something very very normal
wow it's aronian though who's
experimenting aronian nearly never plays
the king's indian defense
um i've only seen him play kind of
variants of the king of the king's
indian if he's in muslim situations
which he is now but is this going to be
i was going to say is he going to
capture the pawn because he just needs a
draw
capturing the pawn is a very good choice
here if you only need a draw because the
main line that black can play is a
perpetual yeah so there are other moves
that black can do though to keep the
game going but capturing the pawn is the
obvious choice i thought lev might might
go knight bd7 instead right to avoid
this but he doesn't he doesn't okay wow
you saw lev there just kind of holding
his breath hoping that magnus wouldn't
go for a drawing line
do you know this h6 move really
fascinating actually just recently in
the top level computer encounters this
has been the move favored by i think the
latest version of stockfish
with the black pieces um this this move
an interesting little slant on the sharp
theory that's out there in the king's
indian defense
so just uh yeah i saw some fascinating
tweets maybe you saw the same by matthew
sadler a big computer
i mean grandmaster but a big computer
chess expert and yeah he mentioned this
right yeah i mean it looks so bizarre it
looks like you're fighting for the
center you're slightly cramped with
black and then you just take a timeout
to push a ball on the side of the board
uh but yeah it's a decent waiting move
it always stops white's dark squared
bishop from coming out uh for example if
we do see an exchange of pawns in the
center of the board white would love to
develop his star squad bishop out to the
g5 square but black keeps that one
under control magnus is surprised yeah
i'm
surprised he doesn't know about this
move actually you know we've seen it he
needs to follow matthew sadler on
twitter yeah that's what he does he
needs to do to be aware of these things
we should all go over right now and
follow him because uh some real nuggets
there are all about computers and their
recommendations totally agree right i
mean totally yeah his stuff is great so
yeah i suspect that magnus does know
though and he's just simply deciding
what to do
and
i'm surprised at this choice because
yeah you know i'm sure computers will
love it and it does take space in the
center but on the other hand play gets
so sharp and magnus will have to defend
on the right side for such a long time
um i wasn't expecting that i expected a
much more um
flexible move such as uh moving the rook
or maybe developing the bishop
committal stuff from the world champion
yeah and uh he is following the wisdom i
talked in that learning point just a bit
earlier that when you need a draw don't
play for it don't uh make negative
decisions but this one is extremely
risky
um this one is going to be a full
blooded fight
i mean aronia must be really happy the
way this has gone because if you if you
again if you in a must win situations
there's certain positions you want
this is one of them where you keep all
the pieces on the board you try to play
like kasparov and checkmate your
opponent on the king side it's as simple
as that so so i think i
i know magnus is playing in the right
way but ronia must be happy right so get
this thing again despite what the
computer says this one is uh just really
tense and it's going to be strategically
really hard to call uh for the rest of
the game
um yeah if it's good enough for gary if
it's good enough for kasparov then yeah
it's good enough for anyone especially
in a muslin situation as black and also
clock times doesn't look like much right
now but ironian
super quick he clearly knows at least
some of the plans for black
maybe magnus less familiar and that
counts for quite a lot in these types of
positions so easy for black to play i
mean i love playing these positions as
black because i love attacking i love
attacking my opponent's king and your
plan of attack here is it's just to
launch them right launch a baby
and uh get that get the f pawn get the g
pawn throw him at your opponent's king
try to checkmate him if it works great
if it doesn't oh there you go you know
so but in a must win situation this is
just uh yeah i'd be very happy to get
this so yeah it is that simple sometimes
and uh we talk about pawn structure
quite a lot but the reason black plays
on the king side uh where the kings sit
is because black's pawns if you look at
them this is the base of his pawn chain
they actually point uh in this direction
those pawns um it doesn't look like much
but if your pawns point in a certain way
that's the side you should be playing on
white's pawns if we look at the central
two at least they do point in the other
direction
so that's the side white normally wants
to play on but meanwhile
i think i've actually seen this as well
this pawn sacrifice uh was this an or
something similar in a game between
anish giri against prague where giri one
is black uh white stepped forward
attacking this pawn and levon just
doesn't care he steps upon forward and
does win this guy yeah we saw something
very similar not exactly this but uh
there i remember that anish just
destroyed uh pragnanda and winning on
demand with the black pieces not so easy
to do but uh yeah this is the best that
uh lebron could hope for actually in a
must-win situation he gets his desire
for fighting chess
and uh trade-off bishops
rook now kicks away the white queen
not sure where she's going back if she
comes if she retreats back this way she
might just get stuck on the wrong side
of the board she might be a target here
uh later on for the black rook for
example
so i'd be hesitant to put the queen back
there i guess
most likely the queen will come back in
this direction
but then black's idea wherever the white
queen goes will be to just occupy some
open lines towards the white king
and
levon will hope that this gives good
compensation
computer again very skeptical giving
white more than plus two advantage right
now but
these are two humans magnus is surprised
and levon clearly in his comfort zone
he's probably looked at this position i
mean this kind of stuff is the very
trendy latest latest stuff in the king's
indian defense in one of the main main
lines
um and the way that lev's moving i mean
at least he's got a good idea about what
to do and it's kind of position i just i
just so much enjoy playing with black
you know i mean just because you can
have some fun here right i mean it's
very easy to play this position as black
because you just point everything at
your opponent's king it's very simple
move every piece near it attack it those
two pawns are beautiful that black has
um you know they they're all you don't
necessarily move them but there's always
the threat of rolling them up the board
uh again i'm being a bit optimistic
black's chances just because i enjoy
playing these positions but it's it's
what you want when you need to win so
i thought you started looking at the bar
simon
uh well sometimes oh [ __ ] is it
erroneous favor oh the bar no
no it's not it's in magnus's yeah i do i
need to look at the bar more really but
listening to you guys i guess this is
the the kind of game where you know with
a human it's it's difficult for a human
to play it's inviting a lot of fighting
chess basically i mean just which we
love yeah definitely i mean just take a
look at black's pieces you know every
single one of them is just primed to
start attacking the white king and
defending is just a very uncomfortable
thing to do
and
well magnus steps back
to the square that david highlighted
earlier and
now the big question is whether levon
will actually use the plan that david
suggested of just shifting the queen and
attacking that uh white queen with his
work
oh i thought he was going to go for it
i was about to say there's another way
you could do it you could start
attacking the white queen with your
knight instead he's just following that
principle of putting all the pieces
towards his opponent's king right
i mean again the the bar does really
like the position so but magnus is he's
got as you say it's harder to defend
he's got to play very accurately now i
would be terrified as white here i've
got to admit yeah it feels like your
queen is actually
on the wrong side of the board it looks
like she wants to attack but she's
fighting a battle alone and she will be
fighting against all of black's pieces
these two knights and the rook are going
to come against her and try to even
maybe trap the white queen later on um
so yeah it's not just the white king
that has to be careful later on these
types of
open files it's also the white queen
lacking squares
and meanwhile what is white's plan i
mean this knight is not really
contributing these two look nice and
pretty as well but
they're not really helping the battle
white's rooks aren't uh joining in is it
time to perhaps uh initiate a set of
trades so i mean moves that i i thought
about playing was first of all giving
the queen some freedom along the fourth
row by pushing the pawn forward the
second one was actually to step forward
with the knight
okay that didn't work
stepping forward with the knight maybe
um i guess you want to back it up by
pushing the pawn forward and supporting
this knight it's definitely possible
magnus chose a slightly different
approach maybe he can still do this he
pushed his pawn forward i guess at least
last resort you can hide back with your
queen if you really really need to
but uh levon just the speed with which
he's playing he's gained time since move
one
i mean he must know i think you're right
simon he must know at least vaguely what
he should be doing here
um if not having studied this exact
position before but he's ready to play
your idea david and put the queen in
front of the king
and then the rook comes over and
everything comes in so there is
there is a lot of danger here uh for
white um as in if as you just
demonstrated that if white has placed
some natural moves he was trapped yeah
you can just get a lost position so he
needs to find something in this position
that's quite clever i feel actually
what about my idea of clearing the
fifth row just because at least now you
have some escape squares yeah makes a
lot of sense and i guess black will
possibly do the same i'm not sure
whether you attack the queen with your
knight or whether you attack it uh with
the rook uh by swinging across both look
very tempting
and now white's problem is okay if say
there's an exchange say
i don't know so you move the problem is
you might get stuck with the queen again
on the wrong side of the board the queen
looks nice and pretty here but black i
mean there's already so many attacking
ideas you could start marching forward
unleash unleash this bishop
into the game you could start bringing
your knight in
yeah you need nerves of steel actually
to play this position with the white
pieces but magnus is going to have to do
that
yeah so let's see how magnus defends
because he's definitely the one
defending in this game and uh also six
seven minutes down on the clock already
magnus
yeah scary times for the world champion
levon actually having more time than he
started with
and
whilst magnus is considering how he's
going to defend this position
well we do have a selfie competition and
i wanted to share with you a few
pictures uh the first one comes from
one of the founding members of dire
straits uh david nuffler who is watching
the show and also composing music maybe
chess will inspire him with some lyrics
or maybe
maybe some beats here there maybe the
music from martial but anyway thank you
for watching david
and uh motshabi is uh watching the show
also from south africa wow so i love the
fact that everyone is watching from all
over the world mauritius south africa
gadanz in poland uh philippines as well
i mean this is just incredible yeah and
finally we have another tattoo
suggestion from get vanderbilt who we
all know he's actually got
two chest tattoos a chess king and queen
with his father's and mother's names
tattooed on his legs oh
that's so cool kind of like david's uh
two bishops idea king and queen bishops
you could be tattoo brothers yeah
[Laughter]
no i mean it's super cool i i like the
idea of twinning and uh if you two want
to enter our selfie competition for a
chance to win the air things view plus
then remember to tweet your selfie using
the hashtag chestchamps
absolutely and i have to say i get a
little starstruck when i see uh because
we've seen them before tweets from uh
david knopfler the man behind dire
straits
very cool to have him interested in
chess and following and composing music
yeah do we think we'll see magnus in
dire straits in this game because yeah
he's just too good today david
it's impossible to keep up with
his puns i think he's going to go on the
walk of his life but i mean that was a
walk of life yeah oh yeah i like that
song it's one of my favorites i agree
it's very nice
meanwhile he's moved his queen one
square forward
it does feel like he's a bit
it just feels a bit stuck this white
queen i'm really afraid for the uh
for her safety long term very natural
move for b for black to develop the
bishop one square now because uh you
bring in some new threats there of
chasing the queen again with the bishop
and just getting the rook ready to uh
play a part i mean this would be the you
know without thinking kind of move
winter i feel
simple
quite possibly strong yeah i mean there
might be other options but this is this
is just a logical move to play move
first think later that type yeah which
lev has been doing uh so far in this
game and again look at the time controls
i mean uh the time should i say left uh
magnus is half the time 11. i'm i'm
quite surprised he picked this opening
because he knows what he's got in store
for himself by going into these kind of
variations
um
and i don't think he was probably aware
of that matthew sadler tweet yeah um
because i don't think he'd have gone
into this if he knew about that idea
matthew sadler made made accessible to
the public
yeah and uh there's so many kind of i
mean all the top chest professionals
nowadays there's so many ways to prepare
i mean when i was preparing during the
olympiad i would use twitter in a way
just to prepare i would use
multiple
kind of websites online of course you
have to download watch your uh kind of
check out your opponent's past games but
there are definitely hidden uh nuggets
out there sorry he didn't play this move
he played this one
going to g7 so
big threat now of the rook coming to
attack the white queen
but yeah twitter is a very viable way
these days to find out opening secrets
people have regularly tweeting
about their own games about opening
ideas and
there's a lot of nonsense out there as
well but yeah
that's
something to bear in mind you've got to
favorite those tweets that are give
those uh little golden nuggets of
information i'll tell you how i've been
preparing actually it's quite funny i
use my phone these days and i play so i
say for instance i'm playing with the
black pieces in the game i play with the
white pieces and i let my phone destroy
me with the black pieces
and i just sit there and it just just
it's so funny how phones without even
barely thinking can just
completely wipe the floor with you
they're pretty strong
i mean they're stronger than magnus yeah
phones i mean like much stronger in
actual fact and yeah i mean yeah it's a
great way it's a great way to train
actually train your lines against a
computer or train the other way around
so you can see what ideas the computer
can find that you wouldn't think of and
often i i would actually um
dave is going to hate me but you know i
had like a game that david maybe played
because he was playing this particular
opening that i was preparing and then uh
i was like okay david played it like
this but my phone
is actually playing it in a slightly
better way
and
or are you actually just preparing for
that big game against david when you get
him you know say alright actually i'm
planning if well i would have to be
using i'm using his opening so what can
i do right yeah catch me out one day if
we play against each other yeah
just know it'll be
i'll be preparing my phone
we did we did just see that i just want
to point out magnus give a look
which wasn't a happy look i think that i
don't know if you spotted that but he
gave a real like i'm not happy with his
position
just a few seconds ago at least yeah i
mean this has gone wrong this is it's
amazing i think if he'd have known about
this tweet he wouldn't have got this
position i think it is actually
knowledge is key i mean information is
uh is king right so and uh nowadays in
the chess world and
you can i mean gaining information the
chess world you can take big shortcuts
you know you don't have to do the work
yourself nowadays other people can do
the work as long as you're
able to have access to the work they've
done and there's many ways of doing this
you just gotta you've got to be aware of
it all really to keep keep up with the
latest uh latest stuff out there yeah at
gm mds that's the that's his twitter
handle
yeah you can find all about these uh
computer ideas
um and he worked with alpha zero of
course so you know any
person who's worked with alpha zero is
going to have some good inside knowledge
of uh computer chess who are the best in
the world now and their ideas so yeah
okay meanwhile magnus does bring his
knight to the edge of the board
i think this one holds together
tactically just about it's hanging by a
thread already for white uh but okay
levon just staring down the camera there
kind of breaking the fourth wall uh and
then
it looked like he didn't even put his
hand on the mouse but her move appeared
oh and uh he brought his knight forward
the magic wand the magic wand just yeah
that was really nice it was very english
actually so i couldn't remember the
actual magical phrase so i'm a big
hermione granger fan
yeah
all right well lavon aronian he is
thinking in this must-win situation in
round three in the fdx crypto cup we're
so happy to partner up with ftx and
svana he's uh in miami with
someone very important from ftx what's
happening svena
i'm here with will evans we all started
floating here listening to you uh kaya
we could we that that magic is actually
working its wonder even here in miami
beach
but uh with will evans from ftx and it
i'd like to say that
this is more of a partnership this
tournament than it is an actual
sponsorship because you guys are really
getting involved with everything that's
going on yeah very much we think like
the web3 space and the work that play
magnus is doing really fits into our
brand and what we're trying to do we're
not trying to just slap our logo on
something we want to be connected to the
sport connected to the people innovating
it and that's why we're just so happy to
be to be here and be a partner you're a
chess player yourself aren't you a
weekly rated chess player but i do love
the game and and i see the game growing
so much right now it's an exciting time
to be in it but i've been trying to i've
been following what has been happening
online now as well it's the the crypto
key it is the interaction with the fans
and can you explain a little bit about
what it is because we see the graphics
all the time on screen yeah so we have
this free to claim cryptokey at
ftxcryptocop.com
you can get involved there's a discord
server i'm watching all the memes going
along it's just like seeing a community
build together in a native way and like
you know in a unique way that i think is
really interesting for chess so yeah
it's a free way to get involved in a
tournament unlike anything that's really
been done before
i see ftx with such a strong presence
now on a variety of sports venues but
but uh
why do you guys choose to get involved
with chess well i think chess you know
we do feel a lot of sponsorships in the
sports space but chess in particular
chess players are always learning about
technology like they're learning how to
get better at things right in a new
technology cryptocurrency and also stock
trading in the united states you know we
we think it's like a very unique way a
unique subset of people that are going
to be very
willing to embrace new technology and
that's why we're seeing like incredible
uh response from them from the community
that we we haven't seen maybe in legacy
kind of partnerships that we also
you have yeah so it's actually chess
players are
your perfect partners in a sense
absolutely like that's why we're we've
had a crypto cup last year we did our
first one and that was the online
tournament this time we're doing it live
in miami we're planning already for next
year and what's to come and yeah we
think we can keep the whole thing going
for for a long time see kaya we are
planning for
ftx crypto cup 2023 2024 2025 right
2025. let's keep it going we'll set it
there's no doubt at all that this is the
future you guys so much entertainment so
much drama on the board and so much fun
and remember you can join in all the fun
in the ftx summer of chess by getting
your free ftx crypto key you download
the ftx app you create your ftx account
using
crypto cup 2022 and you join our discord
community for a chance to win a bunch of
prizes there's actually a hundred
thousand dollars worth of prizes up for
grabs so go ahead and join in for all
the fun all the content all the
competitions lavon ronian he is fighting
hard now in the fdx crypto cup he has to
win this game the bar has been swinging
during this interview with will what's
happening on the board some massive
developments kaia and we have to jump
straight in
we have to show what's been happening
because magnus the world champion has
given up his queen
we left the position around here white's
queen was in big danger but uh here
levon aronian i have a feeling he should
have pushed his pawn forward to stop
what magnus has just done instead black
jumped
in with his knight threatening to trap
this white queen and
magnus just didn't care he pushed his
pawn forward and after an exchange uh
here he allowed a double check a
discover check all sorts of ideas now
along this line magnus did once say to
me that he loves allowing discover
checks because they're so
counterintuitive here the black knight
jumped forward white's king hid in the
corner and uh we got to catch up with
the moves but the white queen now under
fire it didn't even move magnus gave up
his queen just by capturing the black
knight in the center and after the queen
fell suddenly he took back and a big
threat on the board the white rook just
wants to slide across and pin
uh the black queen regaining the
material with interest and levon moved
his queen out the way and the knight
drops back and um just a couple moves
have been made and here levon is
fighting on the other side of the board
the current material is a queen for a
rook and a knight and white has a pawn
so it's actually level material but it's
more about the fact uh the white has so
many pieces the volume of white pieces
and what a move this one is pushing a
pawn forward
um yeah i mean the knight the bishop uh
the rook they look dominant the rook's
coming in soon
what's the idea behind this one though
if black just takes this pawn off
is he just trying to keep the position
closed and bring his brook in or
something i mean that's the only thing i
can think of trying to deny black any
open files for his rook on the other
side of the board and keep control um
well i mean in the end aronia decided
not to do that but uh the question now
in my eyes is can can you shut that
bishop down and
just keep black's pieces out of the game
i mean this move looks so obvious
to play i guess the knight is maybe
hanging on the edge of the board
but you're right simon i mean if you can
get this move in if you can lock down
this black bishop it's
at some point super strong and i think
we saw it just flash up on the screen
temporarily but white white's best move
um was the white knight jumping back at
least according to stockfish and uh yeah
it looks like this is a monster threat
now simon uh the one you mentioned if
black for example takes a timeout okay
he does stop this but then this bishop
would be kicked back to its starting
square the bishop terrible piece just
like we've seen earlier today in some
games the rook blocked in as well and uh
the problem is for black there's an
attack brewing against his king
he's been fired beautiful stuff this is
i mean i mean every move is just flowing
by magnus he's barely pausing
i i saw earlier when he was interviewed
and um
uh they you know he was asked basically
uh it was your kind of position and it
was a more like you know tamer game
anybody said well i don't really know
what my kind of position is and he's
proving that here his kind of position
is any kind of position right he can
play he can play you know these dynamic
crazy positions
so well and people tend to forget that
because they because he can play ending
so well but you can that's why he's the
world champion right you can play
everything incredibly well and he took
his opportunity here and lev didn't take
his opportunity i i heard a quote about
magnus that he's like the only person in
the world that understands how to trade
pieces
and
i was like okay oh well i'm sure there
are more people but then when you see
something like this you're like okay he
understood instinctively like he didn't
even bat an eyelid he just
gave up his queen for the rook and night
and it's just like right
my time now
and uh you see how as simon points out
he's just making every single move
almost instantly
it's just happy time all over yeah and
aronian's downfall in this game i hate
to say it but he's just played too
quickly black still has nine minutes on
the clock earlier when he made those
massive decisions when he was trying to
trap the white queen he had three or
four very good moves but he was just
rushing he still had at that time 12 13
minutes on his clock just investing one
extra minute two extra minutes and i
think levon would have found a better
continuation but now magnus again it's
just that multitude of pieces uh white
is attacking uh with his whole army
right now the two white knights the two
white rogues the white bishop
i mean
there might be a force win i'm just
saying knight takes bishop and the rook
comes in
strikes me as you don't generally want
to exchange off this really powerful
night but you said the master exchanges
if you exchange often it forces a very
promising sequence then you should
always be looking for the the captures
and checks and i love this square for
the rook just because it supports the
bishop coming in the night coming in and
uh is this is this as strong as it looks
bishop like you said coming in the night
coming in like coming in
black do i mean if you go and take a
pawn then at the very least white can
get greedy uh check and win the black
knight uh maybe there's even stronger
maybe you can even just take this pawn
and
threaten checkmate in one move
it's just again it's the pieces look
four against zero four attackers
zero defenders and uh i guess ultimately
this all comes about because levon
played very aggressively in the opening
but it did have a downside and that was
his king safety
like if if there were pawns around the
king we would not be sat there going wow
what a wonderful position what has
a different path
yeah what's this bishop in i think the
other way i mean the other thing you can
learn from this is that magnus was kind
of defending because uh you know lev did
sacrifice pawn lev did get what i
thought and we all thought was a very
dangerous position lev maybe didn't play
smooth david pointed out but how did
magnus turn that around by active
defense he's willing to give up his
queen he's willing to play the most
active idea if he'd kept passive there
he'd probably just are lost so active
defense is
such a key idea to remember um when when
you're playing just try to defend
actually there's a lovely checkmate idea
here isn't there i mean a couple of
lovely checkmate ideas night jumps
forward hillary clinton
yeah the rook lift
there's so many lovely ideas that are
just uh
yeah i mean he's trying to get a swing
pun in the self-pacing
rook swinging over to checkmate
i think he's enjoying this game right i
mean the knight moved to the edge just
looks
kind of harmonious doesn't it and uh
with those knights causing havoc there
yeah look at the black pieces this
knight i mean the old adage goes that
knight's on f8 there is no mate but here
the knight on f8 just does nothing
defensively
it can't move these two squares are just
protected the bishop a loose piece and
the rook still fast asleep at home
uh black's king is just devoid of all
protection or clothing
yeah checkmate is guaranteed at this
point i mean all magnus needs to do is
add his rook to the attack
or add his knight to the attack uh as
simon points out and remember if we see
a checkmate on the board we have
promised our viewers a checkmate dance
have we uh david has okay can i just
clarify i joined it i certainly haven't
you know
they didn't
picks or it didn't
[Laughter]
i hope you see a checkmate wasn't that
yesterday
ah so it's uh it only counts for the
rest of the day
yeah i mean we didn't really specify
whether there was an unconditional
we'll do a little macarena
yeah all right we'll find
i'd like to do the right we have to
celebrate the checkmate we love it when
the players give us have we seen i know
we haven't seen one this this time but
i'm trying to recall the last time we
saw a checkmate on the board in any
champions tour they got to allow it more
didn't we see dubov
checkmate magnus crawls in everything's
masters
2021 season okay i think it was twice he
checkmated him yeah one quarter final
wow that's yeah but it's definitely been
rare yeah yeah yes dave is quite safe i
remember also um
last season we had um
we did have another checkmate on the
board daniel
yeah he allowed it and he actually gave
exactly yeah i remember we praised the
streamer he's he's a he's a gentleman
there's only daniel narendra i think
everyone likes daniel for good reason
he's just
really comes across a lovely guy yeah
and uh we've seen many scenarios where
one player resigns one move before their
checkmated i think there should be in
the contract you know
if you're about to get checkmated show
the audience show us and especially the
beginners yeah especially if it's a
really nice checkmate instructive one or
a pattern that we need to remember
we always try and show it here
afterwards or on the analysis board but
it's more emphatic if if the players let
it happen
i'm worried about this dance now
i have to say
i feel like i am a person of my word and
i should do it you know i should just
try to squirm out of it so then i'm like
i don't know any dance i only know the
blockbuster dance do you remember that
one don't get me to try and demonstrate
it that's crafty that is i mean
do you remember it was like i remember
the small box big box you know you know
okay
that's my dance do you like it small box
big box box
i'm done i'm done
even without the checkmate we had the
dance paradise we had the small and big
box box oh my god i'm going red now
coffee
no pressure magnus you have to deliver
checkmate just to do that
so it's just it's an easy one to
remember right so you could just do that
all night
there you are where simon in this day
and age that people can clip that
no don't don't clip it please
that's enough
david what's going on in the game
please about this what is going on with
the bar yeah the evaluation bar is not
happy with this bishop trade that magnus
has just gone for
um suddenly the black rook i was
complaining about in the corner it has
woken up it has joined the battle
i mean to me it looks like checkmate
still um it's really terrifying for
black all white needs to do is pick up
his knight on the g3 square kind of just
throw it off the board and then the
white rook can swing across and deliver
this kind of lawnmower checkmate the two
white rooks cutting off the black king
mating the black king
but black does have i mean it is
erroneous turn he has this one move
to cut across white's plans and i wonder
what the move is david i mean this is
one maybe one of those positions where
if you find a move you might you might
have some chances
um
looks like if black moves his knight
there'll be bad consequences if black
moose is queen then white's knight on
the g3 square can come forward and
capture on f5 wow king i peaked
do you know what the move is there's
only one move to kind of reasonably
remain in the game and that's to move
the queen
and put a slider two squares to the left
put on d6
ah because you've got a counter
check but even then someone like knight
okay yeah it gets weird 94 yeah knight
e4 is the way to go let's show this
because in the current position we see
stockfish and its suggestions on the
screen um the stockfish here does say
maybe this night jump but
um ivanka you're thinking maybe this
isn't the best maybe actually uh if the
computer's given more time to think then
the best defense is actually to swing
the queen over and there you guys
mentioned uh there is a check threat uh
hitting the white king in the corner so
we block this diagonal we jump into the
center and i guess after a capture the
white rook checks it's not quite
checkmate no dancing yet uh because the
black queen can swing across and defend
but
i i'm assuming that this end game is
very good for white trying to do a quick
count
it's actually level pawns
it's not 100 clear at least black is
still alive uh for the foreseeable
future so maybe this is uh the way to go
um the other defense that the computer
points out on the screen in front of us
is the knight to the g6 square
everything apart from this knight move
or the queen move they lose on the spot
and again maybe the same idea i'm not
sure which way white's knight goes
either this way or into the center
if you jump into the center attacking
the black queen then after the night is
captured again a nasty check the king
moves and
maybe you're support for choice here
maybe you can even just move the rook
across
yeah it feels like you're breaking
through you're about to win the black
knight and the king might not survive
although this is not that simple either
or at least it's not immediately game
over
um black can at least try some tricks
yeah the line the line you've just
showed that david has indicated by the
computer in front of me has actually
been like plus five wow and even though
it came up as the top suggestion here i
mean it looks
it looks quite crushing the way and you
found it straight away um
so it's still very hard for lev to find
find a response here but so in the
current position we're actually thinking
that rather than knight to g6 which um
i mean it's still complicated but it
should be losing for black rather than
this move the best defense um ivanka
said wow and i agree wow because it's
counterintuitive to go away from your
own king to actually defend
and uh i guess it's just the fact that
you're trying to hit the white king
which actually looks nice and safely
tucked away in the corner that's why
it's so hard to find you want to take
this pawn with a check and maybe you
force white to go in for this uh idea of
pieces sorry david even there i think
instead of um
instead of the knight coming in sort of
knight f7 after pawn takes i mean just
uh you have to calculate that as well
and he's gone for nineteen for the night
move okay so he okay you're right simon
maybe this is one idea for white
threatening to come across and deliver
checkmate still mightily complicated but
instead he did jump with the knight and
okay magnus didn't go this way he went
the other way
does this give black any chances
it is a double attack you're hitting the
queen and you're hitting this knight
but where can the queen run to but you
have to save the black queen the queen
has actually moved to the h4 squad well
i was thinking rook h3 is nearly is it
i was like
rook rook h3 is like my first fault but
i haven't calculated it i took away the
rook and after the black queen is
distracted knight f6 is the idea
and uh trying to get some
because perpetually
yeah exactly that's why i i was thinking
by i don't know this kind of stuff was
still super complicated super
complicated black king goes into the
corner yeah
yeah maybe you can take this one uh with
your rook and checkmate is coming and
we have those big things going on yeah
massive things okay we have to go back
to the players now because we're about
to see a draw we will explain this later
and uh we are about to see a draw by
perpetual check
massive drama magnus uh was a bit about
to take under the minute the bar going
back and forth he only needs a draw
and it is going to be a draw nothing
else to do and magnus clinches it what a
game and did we see a handshake but it
is a match loss for lavon aronian losing
one game